we have two small children and it's
woken them up in the middle of the night
before and they're wondering you know is
the plane going to land on the house
neighbors turning to our 8 news now
investigators after they say a plan to
make the sky safer is making their lives
a nightmare they say it's more than just
an inconvenience yeah some are accusing
the government of misleading them eight
New Zealand investigator David charns
getting answers is their cries for help
get louder
it's a familiar sound those down below
don't want to hear there's days where
it's endless
planes taking off from Las Vegas's Harry
Reid International Airport one of the
nation's busiest who hears the planes
over their houses these neighbors all
live in the Western Trails neighborhood
two miles Southwest of two runways Ed
Reed moved here 45 years ago it quickly
evolved into something a lot more that
Evolution came with the Federal Aviation
administration's Metroplex project high
traffic volume restricted airspace a
reconfiguration of traffic flow over the
Las Vegas Valley in the name of
efficiency and safety I just wanted you
to know that I write everything down
Karen Borgman moved here in 1988. I have
a whole bunch she writes down every
plane that goes over the date of the
plane reporting it to an airport hotline
I've been able to read the word Delta on
the bottom of a plane and I'm lighter in
Nevada the Las Vegas Metroplex one of 11
across the country adjusted aircraft
patterns and rude assignments while
Clark County owns the airport the FAA
runs the skies and how to get there this
diagram shows a proposed departure route
taking some planes over Western Trails
it cites a challenge of high air traffic
controller workloads providing a
solution of sending general aviation
aircraft off runway 19 but general
aviation isn't just small planes it
includes noisy Jets even chartered
commercial airliners this map shows
Runway 19 and the now implemented
departure plan taking some planes right
over the Western Trails neighborhood
after they leave the ground they were
kind of promised one thing and they're
doing something else so I feel like we
were lied to Casey Boggess lives under
the path what would you equate that
noise to it's kind of like a giant semi
truck driving down the freeway and
you're just standing there an FAA
spokesperson says planes have always
departed from Runway 19. I know when my
my neighbors in that District heard GA
they were thinking small all our planes
hobbyist planes Clark County
Commissioner Michael naft represents
District a bogus and the group here are
some of his constituents we're kind of
confused on why they're still doing this
plan why they're not listening to
community we don't have the manpower to
meet with individual homeowners
associations or neighborhoods naft
pushed representatives from the FAA for
answers in this 2021 commission meeting
after Metroplex went into effect that
February the number of noise complaints
skyrocketed the FAA saying it doesn't
have a policy of meeting with individual
neighbors that is just not an acceptable
excuse for a policy maker or for a
government official to say that no we
don't meet with everyday citizens during
that meeting the FAA said the procedure
in question was part of a wide-ranging
environmental study and sound model that
model run before the 2020 census uses
population data from 2010 since then the
population in the zip code Southwest of
the airport has increased by 38 percent
the number of homes by 20 bogus bought
his not expecting planes flying right
over yeah we did choose to live near the
airport but the flight pass have been
established for I don't know how long
but the flight pass or the flight pass
in addition to the general aviation
departure plan the FAA says a limited
number of commercial planes use the
route in certain weather conditions
particularly when it's windy an FAA
spokesperson telling the 8 news now
investigators while the route is
primarily for general aviation aircraft
the FAA also assigns it to airliners
when win conditions prevent them from
safely departing on other runways but in
that sound study the FAA kept the types
of planes in their model of making
changes versus doing nothing exactly the
same adding quote the proposed air
traffic procedures do not change Runway
use they're paid for by taxpayer dollars
and they ought to be accountable the FAA
made some changes working with Airlines
to make a Runway 19 departure and right
hand turn a last resort but that's not
stopping large Charter Jets of the same
make and model classified as general
aviation from taking off so now they're
you know finding this little gray area
where it's a private plane but it's a
747. now these neighbors and the county
are left to put up with the noise with
the federal government silent I would
expect some sort of empathy from them
the FAA declined to talk to us on camera
but a spokesperson says the agency met
with neighbors over the course of
several years they say they explained
general aviation could include large
Jets even those chartered commercial
planes that are the most disruptive I'm
David charns 8 News Now